hey how's it going long time
no chat i mean i chat with you guys all
the time
but not like this not vlogging i haven't
vlogged in so long i haven't picked up a
camera and held it myself like this
in a very very long time i've forgotten
everything
so today we already shot a couple of
videos and i was just sitting at my
unboxing station and i thought i don't
like this anymore i'm done i don't want
to
i don't want it i don't want to do this
it's time it's new it's 20 21 time for
change
so now i have to go tell tyler that
that's on the agenda i think you thought
that you were done filming today um
tyler hi what's up i'm archiving
everything on my instagram
because it's new year and um new year
new year
new me maybe is a little too bright
so you were too bright stop
stop doing everything i'm doing stop
down the lens a little bit
no cause like look how bright this is
right that's a little too bright could
also
we're learning about vlogging yeah
that's too bright
hold on i fixed it oh my god look at
this
this is so much better they're so close
to me look at this microphone
i think the brand is called deity deity
i have heard about them
and oh so close to you i want to try
well we're trying it right now so it's
cool because there's two kind of
microphones there's a front and a back
so when i'm talking here
or when i'm talking over here like i'm
getting the behind i'm talking
yeah but i'm back here too and i'm
talking tyler
yo so we've been shooting together for a
long time yeah yeah
like what two year two years two and a
half basically two
oh that has nothing to do with um
what i was gonna say we uh how do you
feel
about my stomach's growling i heard
oh my god i'm so starving it's a good
thing that we ordered food because i
think that we might need
some nourishment for this evening's task
i know that like the setup is pretty
much perfect like lighting looks great
like we got a new
that's all right that's all right i'm
sorry oh really i'm glad to hear you say
that because how about
we completely redo it again what a
spontaneous great idea you just had
it's crazy like i didn't plan this or
anything like i had no idea that this
was gonna happen
fun my initial idea was to shoot from
like this direction
but i don't think that's gonna work and
then i liked your second idea better
where
we go that way yeah toward the entryway
because that gives us even a little
extra depth
we close the bathroom door throw a plant
over there put a light
up there in the hallway one of the
things that we've been doing recently is
we've actually been using this as a
podcasting desk
so we've just kind of swing these off to
the side
when we're doing unboxings and then when
we do podcasts we just go
like that in time for pod oh gosh
i'm stressed out what do we do first
move
everything i haven't vlogged in so long
like my arm's tired
oh my gosh i'm so so tired this is heavy
first
we clean everything out of here that is
not a part
of the shooting setup sometimes we
accumulate
some some mess i feel personally
attacked
it was a personal attack it could not
have been any more personal
or direct i'm disgusting
uh okay we do this now vlogging feels
weird this feels
i'm liking it i missed it this is fun
look at this authenticity
it's 2021 why is this tv so heavy oh
you're gonna hit the door
75 inches
all of
because i also kind of have like this
vision like
chairs like the vintage ones they're
like um kind of like an emerald color
like i have it in my mind it's like um
like a green
like a you would see it like in your
grandmother's house
or something like an arm chair kind of
like
if if i were to like get a book and like
a bourbon
like this is what i would picture myself
sitting at
i have never even had bourbon in my life
i don't even
yeah like something like that but more
like um like little
buttons buttons like a little light like
you would see in a library
oh like this yeah they're already like
that but like in a green
and then like accented with like some
pinks
and some rose gold oh beautiful love it
everything you've got to go
everything's got to go everything's got
to go
you're going to go that way i'm going
that way
you go that way oh i go this way the
whole way yeah
things are coming along nicely we've got
a clean floor so we got this new
aperture light
pretty excited about it it's actually
pretty cost effective which is kind of
incredible because
usually a lot of studio lights are
pretty expensive so this is the 200d
and then what's this this is the 120d
new boy
smaller dome larger dome all right
how are you doing
you hate it you hate it yeah i think you
me sis need to move this desk
okay i move the desk i need to get her
head in the space
there instead of yeah okay yeah
the order i think has been delivered to
the door
oh jeez be careful when you walk out
here because there is a tree i won't run
like uh you don't do it like this is
the food the food the food i will light
it up by
my beautiful garden i got a nice salmon
what you got there a little butternut
squash delight
yeah yeah yeah do you guys remember when
i used to vlog
every single day you don't remember that
time
i've seen some of it though like there's
not there can't be a daily vlogger
that's like
i am happy no
because then they all inevitably
complain about it i don't look at me
no i mean like can't do it anymore it's
hard it is very very hard
props to people that still do it and
can't do it
and you're happy play chill out radio on
pandora
hey i listen to pandora on my homepod
chill out radio now playing on pandora
what is it like 2002
what if we could time travel what if we
are time traveling
what if we have time traveled i
definitely wouldn't go back to 2002. i
wouldn't either
i'd go back before civilization free
newspapers i think i'm just gonna make a
little coffee
just a little coffee
[Music]
okay wow we're just turn on the back
light here a little accent okay
okay hear me out i just feel like we
need a little
nature it's not the worst thing
but it's just kind of did you see what
this looks like over here just because
you know we're doing moving things
oh shoot all right okay
where where do you think um on the
balcony
oh
it's so big no look how small
it looks cool i actually don't hate the
plan there
i would say the other way because now it
looks like it's coming out of my head
maybe turn yours on first okay there we
go
the beginnings of a setup it is we've
already done a lot
i know like why don't we we should be
putting it in this camera
and then i think for podcasts everything
can be dark in the back
tyler hates this tree and then look it's
just like in the place where
you would never put it's kind of just
like blocking that hallway
is there a way to just turn these two
lights on
yeah that's exactly what i wanted
so hold on a second we gotta turn these
ones off though
okay they're not off that looks so
nice it does look good i like it it
looks cool
in the viewfinder too whoa yeah look at
that
tyler hey what up youtube
you hate the truth like now look at the
trees
i don't want to lighten the tree if the
tree if
if the tree's there i think it's lit
enough
right now like it is lit where have you
seen the
gap table tell me you can tell
that i've taped the outlet come
on yeah there's no way i can't even see
what my own eye is
i say we go with this background for now
yeah i like it
all right we did that more to come
i like that light in the back it looks
like the that skylight
yeah that's nice and that's the rgb
thing so
is that just the one by one that's nice
oh
oh you're stuck good yeah uh
new set who dis this is my first video
actually shooting here in the new set so
i'm super excited about it
you